hello everyone and welcome back to
learning with yakman x today I'm going
to be starting a new series with you
where we explore the camera angles from
some of our most beloved horror games
starting with none other than Resident
Evil I'll take you through step by step
how to recreate the iconic liquor
introduction from Resident Evil 2. in
this video we're going to cover fixed
camera angles tank controls and
triggering a animated sequence just as
the camera switches all the basics you
need for a classic Resident Evil game so
let's jump on into the editor I'm using
I'm more engine version 5.1 for this
tutorial however it could also be
relevant to Unwell Engine 4 or 5.23
whatever comes after this I simply
created a new project and used the third
person template so we already have all
the third person assets we need for our
fixed camera scene when you open your
project you will be greeted with a level
similar to this but without all of these
lovely white boxes everywhere I have put
these in because the first step to this
is to white box out our level white
boxing means to literally use boxes and
other placeholder items just to see how
the look and feel of a level will be
before putting in your final assets an
unroll engine is great at providing you
with these quick and easy items to use
so you can just click on one I'll press
Ctrl B and you can see they're all
stored within architecture so the
architecture folder within starter
content within the content folder just
in case you are very new to Unreal
Engine and you're not quite sure how to
place things you literally just click
and drag into the level here I'm going
to delete this out because I don't need
it if you click on something thing it
will automatically allow you to move it
and that you can also make this happen
by pressing W on the keyboard if you
press e on the keyboard you can rotate
like so if you press r on the keyboard
you can actually scale and control Z
brings it back to how it was before you
changed it if you have a bunch of stuff
that's floating you don't have to
manually put it on the floor you can
just hit the end key and it just goes
automatically to the nearest static mesh
below it another handy tip hold down alt
As you move something and you will have
duplicated it I created this based off
what I could see within the Resident
Evil scene that we're going to recreate
today so this is going to be the kind of
starting back room I'm not quite sure
what room that is but he's in this
police room and then he goes around the
corner and this is the iconic First
Liquor moment where he walks and then
there's a liquor that scuttles across
and then he goes into this little door
here and the camera changes to look at
him from outside the window just to make
sure everything is working as expected I
have my player start here make sure that
you put this where you want Leon to
start and if we hit the green play
button we can see
uh little iron iron lady that's what
unreal engine's character looks like so
yeah walking around the scene good good
all looks good now we just want our
fixed cameras in here and we want tank
controls because as you can see the
camera is very free at the moment and
also so is the movement we don't have
tank controls
press escape to get out of that and I
think the first thing we should do is
actually Dive Right on in with some
blueprints so I have actually created a
blueprint folder to create folders you
can literally just right click
and create folder somewhere that new
folder I like to put all my blueprints
in one folder because it helps me to
keep things nice and clean I'm just
going to delete this new folder uh so
I've got a tutorial blueprints folder
and that's where I'm going to put all of
the blueprints we're going to create
today
so in wherever you want your blueprints
to be right click and we're going to
create a new blueprint class
and this is going to be a class type of
actor
and I'm just going to call this BP
underscore so BP just stands for
blueprint so I know what it is it's
easier to search for this way as well uh
fixed camera
yeah
there we go
and if I double click on this one
the blueprint should open for us
all right let's pop this in here so what
we need is a blueprint that can handle
not only camera switching but also when
the cameras should switch so this should
be based off a collision so in the
components I'm going to add a cine
camera
and I'm also going to add a box collider
so box Collision here now there is
camera that you might have come across
before it's just a basic camera viewport
this is the one I do believe that comes
automatically default with the third
person player but I prefer to use cine
cameras because we have more control
over things like Focus
aperture film back as you can see you
have all these settings here so we could
play with it and make it really
cinematic if we wanted to so for ease of
use I am going to make this box pretty
big because it's going to probably cover
quite a large surface area so I'm just
going to make it 500 by 500 by 500 as a
good rule of thumb we always want to
change a collision boxes box extent over
its scale and the cine cameras here I'm
just going to move this up a little bit
because it's always going to be a little
bit further up
maybe 200 will do just to call out on
blueprints compiling you compile to make
sure that any of the the logic within
your blueprint is uh execution
executionable
that's the hard way to say what I like
to do is I click on the three dots next
to it and I say save and compile only on
success only so this means that you
won't have to be constantly receiving
your blueprints all the time saves you a
little bit of time also on the topic of
working smarter go into your class
defaults at the top here and make sure
that start with tick enabled is not true
this will save on some performance and
you'll thank yourself in the long run
what we're creating today won't need to
be ran on tick alright that's a cleanup
sorted now let's go into our box
collision and in the Box collisions
details panel you can see above me there
it has a bunch of settings if we just
roll down
we'll scroll down a little bit better
until you find Collision you could also
just type Collision in the search bar
here and what you want to do is make
sure that the character cannot step up
on this we don't want it to affect
navigation for the character so say no
and uh leave it on over or overlap all
Dynamic that should be fine
okay and now we're gonna compile okay
that's that set up so if we go into our
event graph it's just at the top of the
viewports here
uh you can see that we already have a
few events available to us so we
definitely get one event tick just hit
delete on that one we also don't want
act to begin overlap because we're going
to use the Box Collision for that uh we
will use begin play a bit later we'll
leave that alone for the time being but
if we click on the box component again
on the left and then uh look down to its
events on the right and you should find
con component begin overlap so press the
plus button here and a new event will be
open to you so now we have been given a
event that will trigger whenever
anything overlaps our Collision box but
what we want to make sure is that only
the player will trigger the changing of
the fixed camera angles so in other
actor on the event itself just left
click and drag and in the search box
just search for equal equal
it's basically just like code syntax and
if you don't code then welcome this is
basically coding so I hope you feel cool
so let's press enter and we're going to
use this so this will check to see hey
is the other actor the same type of
whatever object reference we're going to
put here and the object reference we are
going to use is our player character so
we have just been overlapped is the
other overlapping actor the same as
player character and then from the end
point here this is a Boolean which just
comes back with a false or a true and we
can use it to Branch our logic here so
we're going to connect these up so if it
is a player character we can carry on
through and keep doing what we want to
do and change that fixed camera angle if
not we don't want it to do anything okay
so off this true is where we want to say
okay switch the viewport however I'm
going to do this in a separate function
because later on I'm going to show you
how to make child blueprints of this
blueprint don't get scared if you've
never heard that time it's not that
scary let's create a function now so on
the left hand side it says functions if
we click on the little plus button we
can create a new function and I'm going
to name this uh
on
fixed cam
over lap
okay
and here's where I want to put our logic
first of all right click because we need
to get a reference to our player
player camera no player control roller
that is the one
and uh click off this one and we want to
set a view Target yes with blend perfect
that's the one so this is basically
going to go where's our player
controller what is the player
controller's current viewport let's
change it to be the new viewport Target
of whatever we put in to this little
variable here you'd think that we would
just pull our cine camera and say I want
to use this one but no actually I'm just
going to delete that one here if you
hover over it says it needs an actor
object reference and luckily enough
there's a blueprint itself is an actor
object as you can see of the top right
it's parent classes actor so let's left
click and drag off that and we're
literally just going to say ourself
we're just going to get a reference to
this blueprint and then it's going to
say okay what is the viewport in this
blueprint well it's the cine camera
blend time and all of this we're not
really going to worry about because in
Resident Evil it doesn't have any Blends
between the camera viewports changing it
just snaps from one to another but just
to give us the option let's right click
on this blend time here and promote it
to a variable
and I'm going to do the same with blend
funk I guess that's function
and here on the left you can see there's
a drop down called variables and
um you can press the little I and that
means that you will be able to change
what these variables are so this blend
time here above my head says zero right
now but I could put like six of these
into the level six of this blueprint
into the level and each one of them
could have their own blend times so one
camera could take five seconds to go
from the current camera view to that
camera view whereas another one could be
instantaneous and have a blend time at
zero so the only thing left to do now is
to go back into the event graph and from
on component begin overlap of our box
Collision make sure that we're calling
that function we've just created so if
the player is the one that's collided
with it then we want to call on fixed
cam overlap perfect
compile
okay so let's go back into our level and
I'm just going to shove two of the
blueprint in here so I can just show you
I'm just left clicking dragging and
letting go
so one of these are in here and as you
can see we can already see the view
preview of the BP fixed camera from this
blueprint and if I hold alt and drag it
then I have just created a new version
of that blueprint and if I press E I can
rotate it to face the other way the only
downside of using everything in one
blueprint is that it could be pretty
easy to just click on the camera and not
realize that you've clicked on the BP
fixed camera actor as a whole and then
you go to move the camera and actually
you're moving everything you're moving
the Collision box and everything what
you need to do if you only want to move
say the camera and not the Collision box
is to go into the details of that
blueprint and click on the cine camera
component and now I can move it freely
so I'm going to move it right back here
something like that will do for now
and then I want to click on the box and
the same thing I want to move this
independently of the camera so I'm just
going to move over here a little bit and
as you can see you've got the box
extents so as I I'm just clicking and
dragging it really it's updating the
Collision extents of that box so make
this overlap a little bit and with this
one here I'm just going to move the
whole thing back
and then I just want to move the camera
back a little bit
and now let's see if it works
so we haven't locked into this camera
yet but I'll talk to you about why that
is in a second but the Collision was
somewhere around here so we should be
snapping to the other camera view there
we go so we've just snapped to the other
camera view perfect but as you can see
it's actually really hard to know there
we go snap back to the other the other
camera view now it's really hard to know
in what direction you will go because we
haven't set up tank controls and it's a
really confusing pressing back and she's
going forward now and pressing forward
and she's going towards the camera it's
um
it's kind of confusing I don't know
where she is what she's doing so that
worked but you know it would be much
easier if we had tank controls but first
of all let's fix uh why she wasn't
going straight into a fixed camera view
when she went in because as we could see
the player start is actually already
being overlapped by the Collision area
so the Collision area is here and she's
there you can actually change
perspective of the top left of the
viewport and go into top perspective and
uh if you press F because I've got my
player start selected it will focus on
that and you can see a little bit better
these are the lines of my collisions and
I'm definitely within it so why am I not
spawning in and instantly being seen by
my camera let's go back to perspective
here
and let's open up the blueprint so from
what I can surmise the
player character gets spawned in before
this on component begin overlap has a
chance to run
so it's actually missing the first
instance of it being overlapped so it's
not the nicest workaround and if you can
think of a better one let me know in the
comments I'm all ears but I'm just going
to put a slight delay here to allow the
player character to spawn in before we
actually check in the overlap whether we
should have this specific camera be the
one that is active
um so here is the delay and then I'm
going to get our box uh collision and
I'm gonna say is overlapping actor yep
that's the one and uh look for our
player character again so
it's kind of a duplicate of what we're
doing here but because that one's not
being triggered on begin play we're
basically just doing a manual check
after a delay of 0.5 seconds so wait for
0.5 seconds wait is the player in this
collision and if it is and we can go
from Return value then we Branch again
if it is then we just want to do this
call of on fix cam overlap we can also
just create another one maybe it'll look
a bit nicer
so this is these are both going to the
same place even though it's calling it
twice it's going to the same function
that we have created
so that should fix the beginning issue
that we had so let's go back to our math
again hit play and then there you go
there was a slight delay of 0.5 seconds
but now she's here
and uh oh gosh yeah I really need to fix
these
tank controls I can't even figure out
where she's going it's so confusing I
don't know she's gone
she's gone now it is time for the tank
controls so if we go into our settings
which is up the top right here we won
the look for World settings so click on
that one
and it should open up a tab somewhere
for you that says World settings on it
and uh what we're looking for is our
game mode so here it says game mode
override and you can see it's using VP
third press and game mode there's
actually a little folder and you can
browse to the asset in the content
browser using this button so I'm going
to left click on that one and here we go
this is our third person game mode the
game mode basically defines all of the
rules of your game including what porn
class you would like to use and a pawn
is the player character and how it's set
up to look how it's set up to animate
and how it's set up to move so this is
what we need to change for tank controls
the VP third person game mode is what
comes with the third person preset that
we loaded with so I don't really want to
change this just in case you want it to
be available to you so I'm gonna just
duplicate this one so right click
duplicate and I'm going to make this uh
tank controls game mode tank controls
game mode and I'm gonna do the same for
the BP third person character because if
you do double click and open up this
game mode there's a lot going on all you
really care about here is default porn
class and you can see it's using BP
third person character and if you click
on the little folder again and minimize
this one it's showing you that it's this
one the BP third person character so
right click on this one
duplicate again and again we're going to
be using
uh actually we'll just put an underscore
here and say tank controls so it's a
third person character tank controls
okay so double click and open up tank
control girl
we can call her now this is how unroll
engine has already set up the third
person character for us as you can see
it's got the camera input and this
allows a player to change where the
character is looking based on their
Mouse movement so we actually just want
to unhook that because we want the
camera to be stationary at all times
please
and here is movement input so this is
what we want to change as you can see
they've got left and right movement
input and they've also got forward and
backward for tank controls what makes
them really useful for fixed camera
angles is that forward will always stay
consistently forward backwards
consistently backwards and left and
right really just rotate the player so
if you press left you're not going to
move left you're just going to look left
and then you can press forwards and
again the momentum will always be
forwards so this is what we are going to
change here so I'm going to just change
this comment so I know what it is and
I'm just going to put tank in it so I
just changing it by double clicking on
it and we don't want to add any movement
input on left or right we just want it
to affect the rotation so I'm gonna
completely remove that and if we get a
reference to our player control ola
player controller yeah yeah
then what we want it to do is change the
rotation
Ah that's the one we wanted to set
control rotation here
so as you can see we need a rotator and
none of these outputs here are going to
give us one so we have to create a new
Rotator so if you're just right here
Rotator scroll right down and make
rotator
and then it will allow us to create our
own one we can delete the get right
vector and what we want to do is plus
not pause plus add the action value X
to the return value Zed your of the
control rotation and this will be our Z
on the Rotator that we've just created I
don't need this little node here so I'm
just gonna
delete it to make it a little bit
cleaner and then we're going to get the
control rotation and hook that up to X
and Y so basically all we care about is
the player putting the action value of
left and right which is X are they
plusing it or minusing it so are they
going left or are they going right and
that now is just going to change the
rotation of the Z of the player
controller instead of actually making
the move anywhere it's just going to
change your rotation
so um
let's hook this one back up now
and we definitely want forward and
backward to be still hooked up we didn't
change anything to do with forward and
backward that one can stay as is and the
last thing that we want to do for our
tank controls to work is to go into the
class settings at the top here
and in the details we just want to
search for your
um nope make sure that the BP third
person character is actually
selected in the components first and
you're looking for a yes Pawn use
controller rotation your we want to
enable that
and that should enable the tank controls
to work okay and then back into our map
here we can just go into the tank
controls game mode that we made and in
the default Pawn class we can change
that to BP third person character tank
controls I've got two because I did make
this earlier but it will work trust me
now compile
and the last thing we need to do now is
go back into our world settings and make
sure that the game mode override is
using the new game mode that we just set
up so just search for tank and there you
go bpe tank controls game mode and now
when we press play
she should be exhibiting tank
controls I'm pressing d right now and
she's not moving anywhere I'm pressing a
and she's not moving anywhere
and then forwards will always be
forwards
ah W is always forwards no matter where
she's looking brilliant
cool now we just really need to sort out
these cameras because
they are bad let's sort these out okay
so I'm just going to use my reference of
the Resident Evil scene that we're
recreating so make sure that all the
cameras kind of line up where I want
them to be so bear with me I'll probably
speed this one up just don't forget that
if you want to change your camera you
need to actually click on it in the
details panel click on your camera
and update that one
while I was setting these cameras up I
just realized they're very zoomed in and
I think I want my cameras to not be
digital film so this is one good reason
why I created the blueprint I can
literally just go into BP fixed camera
go into my cine camera and change the
default film back to be
um DSLR
so let's use that compile that one and
now all of my cameras in my scene no
matter how many I've got will now be
updated to use DSLR and there you go
yeah that's a lot less zoomed in I much
prefer that so you can kind of play
around with these cine camera settings
and see which ones you like
um while I'm in here as well actually I
might just turn off the focus settings
um and we can do auto focus in the next
video of this tutorial series I think
but anyway back to me setting up my
cameras
one thing to note as well if you want a
smoother movement snapping on the
cameras you can press uh this one here
the little grid of the top right of the
viewport right now mine's on 10 and if I
wanted to make it even smoother my
movement snapping
I can make it five so that's movement
here but if I want my rotation snapping
to be smoother I can make that five as
well so the rotation ones right next to
it and you can also just turn it on and
off if you want no snapping at all
but uh yeah something like that I should
do think and as you can see from the top
down perspective I've got all my
collisions lined up where I would like
them to trigger the next camera this
Collision actually needs to be way
bigger
trying to make sure that they are lined
up it doesn't so much matter if they
overlap too much because we don't really
care about what happens when the player
exits the Collision it's just what
happens when the enters another one
something that could really help
actually
um to
see where these Collision boxes are
because I do understand they're pretty
tiny if you go back into VP fix camera
click on our box Collision in the
components and we could actually up the
line thickness to something like 10 and
that should make um a much more
noticeable here so you know where they
are one thing I'd also like to say while
we're here you can pin the preview of
whatever camera you have selected so it
will always stay on your viewport so I'm
just going to pin this one now and I
notice in my reference that there is
like a little a little cylinder thing in
this room so I'm going to just switch me
over for a second
um I have gone on to my shapes which is
in place actors and you can see I've got
like Cube spheres cylinders
I was going to call that a scone then
cones and planes I'm going to use a
cylinder actually here because that's
the right shape for what I can see
in my Resident Evil reference I'm just
going to scale it up a little bit and I
could actually scale it uh so it's a
little bit taller and that's what I am
seeing in my reference so this is
exactly what white boxing is really good
for it's it's knowing okay how does the
space look with all of the elements like
a bookshelf or whatever this is I don't
even know what the what is interested in
the Resident Evil one how are they going
to affect your environment without
having to actually make the assets first
and place them you can just kind of
figure out the scale and maybe it
obscures something I don't know it's
there for a reason and you want it to be
replaced with something in the future
white boxing is good for that
okay so let's press play and I'll show
you what I've got so far
there she is oh we can unpin this now as
well
um okay so she's here with her little
time controls she's walking around
and I can see that in my reference
footage as well Leon's head does get
kind of cut cut off by this thing that's
here
so that's uh pretty decent and then
there's a collision here so it should
switch yep switching over here when she
gets to this area and then she starts to
walk towards the camera and this is when
the dramatic liquor animation will
happen
and we'll do that in a second and this
is the very cool I love these out the
window shots that old fixed camera games
used to do so um yeah that's there if we
go back have we lost her now she's there
if you go back say We'll flip back to
the old camera views and yeah we've
we've made quite a lot of stuff there
where we could have some good fun with
that but I think what we need to do is
um trigger off that all important
animation only when the camera changes
so at the very moment the camera changes
the animation of the liquor comes and it
won't happen again so it's a one-time
only thing let's quickly do that now
so you might have noticed there were
some little blue boxes out here these
actually are just boxes that come with
the default level that loads up but you
can use any boxes I'm just going to use
these but you could literally just use a
cube from your place actors here
if you wanted to and I'm just going to
use one of these and this is going to be
our spooky spooky liquor oh gosh how
terrifying and the way that we're going
to animate It Is by using a level
sequence so if we go into our cinematics
in place actors you will see something
called a level sequence actor so if you
could please left click drag and drop
that into your scene for me I would be a
very happy girly and I'm just going to
right click it in my outliner as well
and rename it so everything's nice and
clean for me where's the rename Button
as in edit rename okay so this is going
to be liquor and um and let's just say
LS level sequence look at them cool
and actually I'm also going to right
click and
move to cinematic because I've got
everything in folders here so we've got
a level sequence actor and as you can
see in its uh details tab which my head
is now over again so one second it does
need a reference to a level sequence
asset this level sequence actor that
we've called LS liquor annum is going to
play whatever level sequence asset we
put in here so right now it says None
and if you click on the drop down even
if you have never made one ever I have
made one in the past When I Was
preparing for this tutorial but you can
still click create new level sequence up
here so that's what we want to do create
new level sequence and again it's up to
you where you put it I like to put all
mine in a folder called cinematic so you
can right click new folder so I've
already got my cinematics folder and I'm
going to create liquor annum sequin
this bar was grayed out before the open
level sequence but now it is not we can
click on it
and it is going to open the sequence for
our liquor and M sequins it will be
empty there's going to be nothing there
but there is a little tab down here for
the sequencer click on the box or
whatever you're using to represent your
liquor and then click on the plus track
button within the sequencer Tab and
actor to sequencer at the very top it
says add and it will be whatever you
have selected so make sure you only have
whatever you want to be the liquor
selected
so I've added that in now
and all I really want to do is show this
going from the bottom right of the
window to the bottom left so it'll be
like it's crawling up there obviously
this is very placeholder in the game you
would have it
um play an actual animation it would be
an actual rigged character but I think
this is good enough to show you how to
do it we want it to save the location
and one thing what's really handy is to
make sure that you have this create a
key when channels properties change
enabled so this will just automatically
create Keys whenever I move it now so
say if I moved it to frame 50 and now I
move it to the top left of my window
then it's already tracked the location
if for some reason that doesn't work
though don't worry you can just click on
the little add new key button here
and that again will track anything
uh that the cube or whatever actor
you're tracking is doing at that time
with their location
so to preview this you can literally
scrub through so I can see I'm going
left right
so spooky
and um you can also press
the play button I'm Gonna Save it
actually make sure you're saving
press the little C button so down the
very bottom
there's little track options and you can
press play here
now one thing you'll notice is that went
on for a long time that's because my
level sequence is set to be 150 frames
really we just need it to be really
quick because all I wanted to do is go
from from here to there
so how do we activate this level
sequence as soon as the camera switches
good question I mentioned before that we
were going to be making a child
blueprint of our fixed camera blueprint
and we're going to do that now so go
back to our BP fixed camera you can just
click on BB fixed camera in the world
outliner and then Ctrl B if you have
lost yours and uh right click on it and
create child blueprint class so as it
says here this creates a child blueprint
class based on the current blueprint
allowing you to create variants easily
it's right up the very top here I'm kind
of covering it a little bit but I think
you can still see it
so click on that one and here we have BP
fixed camera child but I'm going to
rename this to be called sequencer
BP fix camera sequencer
so double click to open this one
now what you have in a child blueprint
is everything that it shares with its
parents so it already has the Box
Collision it already has the cine camera
anything you change in the parent will
also be changed in the child so it's
really good to work this way if you know
that you want
um a blueprint that shares a lot of the
same functionality as another blueprint
but you just want to add something very
particular to it which is exactly what
we're doing here we want the fixed
camera angle to change but at the same
time we need it to trigger a sequencer
so we still want to use the same
blueprint we just want to add stuff to
it and that's where a child blueprint
becomes very handy so let's go into our
event graph as you can see it's already
going to play our parents begin play
which is Handy Dandy we can delete these
sticks we don't need them and what we
want to do is find our parent function
that we created earlier called fixed cam
overlap that's it event on fixed cam
overlap
and uh this will get triggered whenever
our parent blueprint has triggered their
function so on fixed cam overlap we want
to right click and add a call to the
parent function to make sure that it's
still going to do the logic that we set
up in the parent so it's still going to
switch to our cine camera here
but now we want to add some extra
functionality to trigger a sequencer so
before we put any logic in we need to
make sure we have available to us a
sequencer in the first place so let's
add some variables we want to add a
sequencer
to play
and let's make this a type of level
sequence
actor
okay
and again we want to click the little I
so that it can be editable I'll also
just add some little booleans here so I
want to ask
should the sequencer just play once
so a Boolean again is just a false or a
true
and we want to make that public as well
should it Loop because we could have
instances where we want the sequence to
Loop and if it should Loop then how how
often should it Loop so Loop amount
maybe you want to have full control over
this and that'll be an integer so an
integer is just a rounded number you
can't have any decimals in an integer
and I will also do one more Boolean
which is has the sequencer played
if we only wanted to play once we need
to know when it has already played so
those are all publicly editable so we
can change those on per instance of this
blueprint being in a level first things
first let's get the reference to our
sequencer I'm going to right click here
and just look for convert to validated
get
now this just creates a get function
that just looks for is this sequencer
valid
if it is valid carry on if it's not
valid then let's just put a print string
and say
no sequencer found
so a print string is really good for
debug uh let's put it on for like
10 seconds it's really good to put some
print strings in if you're ever trying
to debug why something's not working or
in a case like this perhaps it'll be
very easy to accidentally forget to to
hook up the sequencer to this blueprint
so it you'll always know oh something in
here isn't working because it doesn't
have a reference to the sequencer if it
is valid then we want to check for
whether it should be played once and
also whether the sequencer has played at
all
um if the sequencer has played as you
can see the default value of a Boolean
is always false you can see that in the
details panel here on the right but you
can change the default value you can say
yes
that it has already played but you don't
want to do that for this don't do that
for this and for that point actually I'm
going to make sure that this is not
instance editable because there's no
reason for us to ever want to say
whether a sequencer has played it's
purely for gameplay prefaces so this has
a closed eye whereas all of our other
variables we've set up have open eyes
I'm going to do a check on both of these
so what this will be checking for is
the sequencer Play Once yes
and has the sequencer played yes in that
case
then we can put a branch here and if
it's true then we could say another
print string
sequencer has played once so well no
longer play
we say played once and is set to only
play once so we'll no longer play and I
can change the color of this to like red
and again I'll give it like a duration
of 10 seconds so we won't miss it on the
screen
uh and this this is a good check to do
because we want it to only play once so
if play wants for Trans false but the
sequencer has played is true then it'll
still return false because one of them
is false
okay so let's get this one out of the
way
now we can check for the loop so
should this sequencer Loop get
and branch on that
if if yes it should Loop then we could
say well we need to get a reference to
our sequencer so let's drag that one in
here and we should say play looped
looping here we go
so that's automatically got us a
reference to the level sequence player
object
so yes it should be looping then let's
play looping and number of Loops so as
you can see default is minus one so
actually I'm going to put on my Loop
amount the default to be minus one what
this means is that minus one Loops means
infinite it will Loop infinitely it will
never stop looping if you put a loop
amount of zero then it won't Loop its
number of Loops will be zero
um one will mean it Loops once two twice
you get the picture
so yeah I'm keeping this default amount
to -1 but if we want to change it
because it is publicly editable then we
can
and we're just hooking these ones up
here
and if we don't want it to Loop then we
could just play as it is
we don't need to use the play looping
there's an even simpler load for that so
if you go back to our map now we need to
find the fixed camera blueprint that
will need to trigger the sequencer and
we need to change this to use the new
child actor we've just created if I
select the child blueprint in the
content browser here right clicking on
the one in the outliner the one I want
to replace I'm choosing replace selected
actors with and I've already have my BP
vix camera sequencer selected in the
content browser so I'm going to click on
that one
and it doesn't reset the camera or
anything because they are a child
blueprint so it doesn't look like
anything has changed but it has if I
just
take this one out for you you can see
the type
here says edit BP fix camera sequencer
so we have just replaced it with our new
child actor
magic I'm going to rename it just so I
know what it is my name please
sequencer okay and now let's give this a
crack oh wait hold on let's have a look
at the details of this one
because I didn't show you the details of
the other blueprints that we made so we
can look in the default section of the
details tab of RBP fixed camera
sequencer and you can see here it's got
sequencer to play Aha see it wouldn't
have worked so I haven't set that up yet
and I've got played ones should loop
loop amount all of this stuff and the
blend time and the blend function that
we set up uh from our parents so the
blend time is zero that's why our canvas
are snapping nicely we don't want to
Loop them out so this is good it
shouldn't Loop so this is good but we do
want it to only play one time so I'm
gonna put this to true and then I also
need to set the sequencer to play so I
can actually just click on none and I
can say liquor anime but there's also
this little picker tool and I can click
on that one
and if you can find your level sequence
in your scene you can click on that one
and just
pick that that there but I've already
got mine set up so there we go that
should be
everything's set up uh to go so I'm just
gonna save
my map and then press play
then here we go so
she's going she's going she's uh
gonna go down this little corridor
oh my God
so spooky
it's so stupid I love it and now if I go
back
why is it doing that
oh okay so do once it's not working
because it's doing multiple times I know
what we forgot
I say we I mean me you didn't do
anything wrong I am the teacher here
um so if we go back into our fixed
camera sequence we did not
let me know in the comments if you
already realized that I didn't do this
we didn't set has sequencer played we
need to say that the sequencer has been
played so we're going to set this to be
true
compile so it's going to go through here
and if it gets to play either looping or
play just once it will say okay yeah
we've played it now
and then back here in this check of play
once it can also update this one so what
was happening then was play once was
true but has sequencer played was never
true it was always false it was always
coming through here so if we try one
more time
then
spooky scary
just go there and then back down again
there you go sequencer has played once
and is set to only play once so we'll no
longer play
[Music]
and that's it I really hope you find
that useful I guess one thing I could
show you that I haven't shown you yet is
that it'll blend so on BP fixed camera
two I'll just quickly show you in the
details panel in default I'm going to
set its blend time to like two seconds
and you'll see what blending looks like
but for Resident Evil camera Styles you
won't really need this see so it's
slowly blending over the only thing is
you don't have control over that blend
right now I can show you how to in
future videos so let me know if you want
to
um but yeah for Resident Evil you really
just want the blend to be at its default
for zero and you will get nice clean
snapping and there you have it now you
have recreated one of the most iconic
moments in horror gaming history I hope
I've also shared with you some values of
how you could create blueprints you know
the different between a parent and a
child creating variables you can change
publicly in the level hopefully there's
enough in there for you to kind of go
away now and play with them yourself if
you're a Game Dev let me know if you
would have set this up a little bit
differently in the comments down below
and let me know if you know a workaround
for making the correct camera play on
begin play because yeah I couldn't
figure that one out with my little
Noggin but I'm sure us as a community we
can come up with something a little bit
better than adding a delay there we only
touched on level sequences in this video
but if you want to learn more about how
to utilize Admiral engines cinematic
tools and in particular the sequencer
you can check out my other video all
about how to trigger gameplay via the
sequencer and if you enjoyed this video
I would love for you to leave a like it
just lets me know that these videos are
well received and that you want to see
more of them because I would love to
turn this into a series I'd love my next
one to focus on silent hill much more
where this came from just so you know I
have moved all of my gameplay footage
over to my second Channel gaming with
yagman X so please check that out if
you're missing me playing games like
chicken evil hey
oh damn and also I'm live on Twitch
every single week so I would love to see
you in the chat we do Monday morning
motivation streams where we set out
weekly goals and I also just play games
so links are in the description down
below and as always a massive thank you
to my patreons who got to see this video
before any of you peasants on YouTube so
you're not peasants as soon as I said
that I was like that's so mean don't say
that they get to see Early Access videos
uh there's a pen pals here where I send
handmade cards to you you get MP3
versions of the songs that I create and
and more goodies go check that out if
you're interested and just thank you to
everyone who is I really really
appreciate all
as always it's a pleasure to share what
I know with you and to learn from you in
the comments I'm sure I will thank you
for watching have a lovely day or
evening
yeah I guess that's that
you still here oh
my light just changed color I don't know
why I did that
okay I think I think that's good I think
we're good I think we're good
this new format is very new for me I
hope you like it
I don't know